geht das auch okay war ich weiß nicht ob
ich das ich bin dass man jetzt nicht ein
ich versuche es einfach mal server 1 hat
nicht funktioniert also ich bin jetzt
wirklich mal gespannt ich schau mal soll
ich jetzt schon drunter schauen ich
zeige dass mal in die kamera
leute was geht ab und damit herzlich
willkommen auf dem wahrscheinlich nicht
besser reaktions kanal auf ganz youtube
es war schwierig falsche begrüßen das
machen zurzeit so auf leute schickt auf
jeden fall meinen neuen reaktions kanal
auf erster linie in der beschreibung
abonniert
was geht ab und damit herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ich
befinde mich gerade im auto heute ist
der erste mai eigentlich welcher zum
fahrradfahren und die ist das aber
genauso wie es nicht geht dass es so
aussieht als hätte ich haare auf dem
kopf
also ich hab eigentlich haare auf dem
kopf in der kamera sieht so aus als
hätte ich keine haare auf jeden fall
machen leute auf ganz entspannt eine
neue folge ich teste wir alle tiptop
live-act ich habe wirklich also ich weiß
dass das in letzter zeit wenig aufgabe
aber es gibt einfach noch so viele geile
sachen die ich gerne ausprobieren möchte
wie zum beispiel den ersten heute
deswegen wenn ihr auch weiter bock drauf
habt lasst auf jeden fall nach oben da
und wir schauen uns jetzt den ersten an
das wird komplett meine welt
revolutionieren wenn das gen für reiter
mit dem kids alle leute habt ihr das
gesehen das heißt auf dem boden von
diesem happy meal verpackung ist so ein
sticker dasteht irgendwas mit proof of
purchase habe ich das jetzt richtig
ausgesprochen natürlich weiß ich das ist
ein amerikanisches video aber warum
sollte das in deutschland nicht auch
gehen obwohl man das eigentlich auch
wüsste und ich hab da auch noch die
nachwuchsgarde fans einfach mal los
checken das ab und ich stelle einfach
mal mehrere happy meals aber ich freue
mich auch vielleicht ist ja gar nicht
auf jeder verpackung doch deswegen
bestellen wir einfach mal ein paar mehr
hallo ich hätte gerne zwei happy meals
beide mit kies bürger bitte
dankeschön
ich kriege noch was was kriegt dennoch
hat hier hat gesagt ich hab alles okay
leute was geht
ich habe jetzt zwei hätten jetzt gekauft
ich habe gedacht bevor die jetzt drei
kaufst so viel will ich jetzt auch in
essen eigentlich habe ich sowieso keinen
hunger aber ich kann man ja auch
verschenken also ich bin jetzt wirklich
mal gespannt ich schau mal soll ich
jetzt schon drunter schauen ich zeige
dass mal in die kamera
da muss jetzt was drunter stehen also
bei dem typ mit dem video war das ja
voll mit infos und runter bringt
eigentlich gar nicht aber das heißt ja
nix wir haben noch ein zweites
was haltet ihr euch auch mal in die
kamera kann man da irgendwas sehen ich
gucke noch nicht hin und man wird sich
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen das war
mir schon klar aber ich fragte es muss
es ja gegeben haben ich will das mal
kurz google und weil on the bottom auf
ihre happy meal okay okay leute ich hab
das jetzt rausgefunden ich kann es euch
hier gerne einbinden also das geht das
muss allerdings eine aktion seien die
läuft nicht immer und wenn die läuft
brauchst du zehn happy meals um eins
umsonst zu bekommen also du kriegst
nicht immer ein neues wenn du einen von
diesen codes so wie es eigentlich im
video erklärt wurde oder also das finde
ich richtig nah es wahrscheinlich gab es
schon mal und ich wusste es einfach
nicht aber gut aus dem alter bin ich
raus trotzdem ist es an sich manchmal
möglich wobei ich weiß nicht ob das auch
in deutschland geht schreibt sie über
gern mal eure meinung in die kommentare
wir sehen uns jetzt gleich zu hause
wieder und dann fühle mich mit meinem
bruder weiter ein bisschen cooler wir
haben nämlich auch ein paar auf lager
die haben es echt in sich let's go so
leute auf geht's zum nächsten und zwar
jetzt wird interessant und vor allem
wichtig weil wer kennt es nicht man will
mal wieder so richtig dick saufen aber
du christ die weinflasche nicht auf
genau das problem habe ich nämlich
gerade
ich will die auf ex trinken aber ich
habe keinen wein öffner und da habe ich
so einiges gefunden
ich weiß nicht ob es klappen kann aber
ich würde es gern mal testen weil ich
hatte wirklich schon ab und zu mal das
problem ist dass ich jetzt wirklich auf
wein trinkt oder so mag ich noch gar
nicht so gerne aber das problem tritt
wirklich auch ich bin euch das super
gerne hier mal ein also im ersten
versuch haben wir hier so einen typen
der dreht an der schraube reihen und
zieht das dann gleich mit einer gabel
raus weiß ich ob mit gabel dafür
geeignet ist sonst kann man ja auch eine
zange nehmen und im zweiten teil haben
wir noch sowas da wird die mit einem
schlüssel auf gemacht also das glaube
ich nicht dass es funktioniert das mit
der schraube glaube ich schon deswegen
versuchen wir das macht
wo sind die schrauben wie sich mein kind
strom zu hause hat wir haben noch
schrauben hier ja aber anders und jeder
folge zu hause das war ehrlich gesagt
hast du eine zweite flasche du hast ja
die firma gerade ich kann doch nicht
erfüllen
das ist doch gekriegt so gar nicht ein
weil ich ganz zufrieden
[Musik]
handy ist kaputt ist okay leute nächster
versuch jetzt habe ich hier eine
schraube mit spitze und schraubenzieher
und jetzt muss es gehen willst du deine
einschätzung meinst du das klappt ist
eine schraube ist die geht doch schon
mal gut rein
das reicht doch schon vor regen dann
kannst du mal die flasche halten länger
warum ist die natur schwierig also das
fühlt sich gar nichts ja nein schraube
raus nein was umdrehen die verstellung
und warum jetzt der korken ist rein
gerutscht
die kommen jetzt komplett drin ich gebe
auf man also ich muss sagen so leicht
wie im video geht es auf jeden fall
nicht das ist fake oder ich will einfach
nur schlecht ich weiß es nicht
moment mal mein live-act wäre den korken
einfach reinzuhauen weil dann kannst du
auch die platz
[Musik]
wobei das ist jetzt einfach neues motiv
oder ist allerdings kunst aber die
flasche ist auch schmeckt aber nicht
weitere vor ihr weitermachen ich muss
erstmal kurzen teller gläser sammeln
dass wir auch also das ist das würde
mein leben verändern
naja ich weiß dass du meinst oben da
drin
jetzt sind alles verschiedene aus
verschiedenen monaten dann würde ich
sagen schauen wir uns den clip man etwas
wirklich will auf also es war toll aus
muss ich sagen als ich das zum ersten
mal gesehen habe also an sich wenn man
sich das vorstellt das ist ja wirklich
sehr sehr hilfreich oder also ich mach
das doch mit einem fingernagel auf das
noch ein bisschen ekelhaft ich weiß aber
dass im video waren ein ganz neues
nutella glas wie zum beispiel auch
dieses hier und da es einfach sein
weißes messer drin vielleicht ist das ja
wirklich so aber gut man braucht auch
erstmal messer und überhaupt an das
messer ranzukommen also irgendwie ist es
dann auch wieder ein bisschen näher mit
dem ich glaube das ist das älteste ist
auch schon mehr so zeigt
hier hätte doch direkt eine alufolie
sein müssen oder danach kommt auf jeden
fall nichts mehr machen mit dem weiter
das ist das nächste älteste auch nicht
dann haben wir jetzt dieses hier also
jetzt ich finde meine hoffnung
eigentlich schon wieder ein bisschen
muss ich sagen ach komm man l und jetzt
noch das ganz neue ich weiß nicht wie
alt das ist vielleicht bezieht sich das
auch wieder nur auf irgendwelche anderen
länder und deutschland macht da nicht
mit nutella deutschland halt aber und
auch das also das war wirklich eine
sache am anfang dachte ich okay das muss
gehen weil das da so viel aus dem video
das messer passt ja auch gut da rein
also von der farbe ja und so auch das
ist absolut fähig
in kanada ist echt so etwas leckeres ne
machen wir weiter mit demnächst wir
haben bereits im vorletzten part eine
möglichkeit wie man jegliche filme
kostenlos im internet schauen kann und
das hat allerdings nicht mit jedem film
geklappt ein paar gehen aber nicht alle
und jetzt wird mir noch 1 angezeigt oder
ich habe eins gefunden da kann man wohl
alle filme schauen das ist eine app ich
denke es illegal das checken wir gleich
mal wir schauen uns erst mal das video
an let's go kostenlose filme anschauen
für apple gitterfenster und schreibt
watch at tv kommt es raus draufklicken
herunterladen leidet ihr hier drauf hier
draufklicken und indesca eingeben und
weiter so hat sie alles neue viel mehr
neues wasser
okay gut dass er einfach aus wir
downloaden uns man die app das muss ja
gehen
safe also watch it tv badaboom auch
schon heruntergeladen dann öffnen wir
die ich kann eigentlich jetzt direkt
schon folgendes dazu sagen und zwar kann
ich mir sehr gut vorstellen dass man die
app auf jeden fall legal herunterladen
kann konnte ich ja auch alles was im app
store es ist auch egal wenn man
allerdings jetzt auf diesen punkt server
zugreift ich glaube das ist dann illegal
also wir versuchen es mal kuh.de weiter
wo er wird analysiert auflösungen auch
schütz und wir haben wirklich wir haben
wirklich viele filme kommen wir hier
beliebte serien ist kann man hier dann
so schauen heraus des geldes riverdale
geht das auch okay warte mal ich weiß
nicht ob ich das ich bin dass man jetzt
nicht ein ich versuche es einfach mal
server 1 hat nicht funktioniert ja heute
also das funktioniert das wusste ich
auch vorher schon
trotzdem empfehle ich euch das natürlich
nichts zu tun also es geht ob man das
wirklich riskieren will ist jedem selber
überlassen da braucht euch dann doch
lieber netflix zu 7 euro oder so weil
das ist wenigstens legal und wenn da
irgendwie ip adresse findet sind das
schnell mal ein paar hundert euro bis
1000 euro vielleicht auch noch mehr die
man einer strafe zahlen muss also ich
lösche die app auf jeden fall wieder
weil ich brauche das nicht trotzdem
funktioniert die leute danke fürs
zuschauen ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
lassen um nach oben da wir hatten heute
wirklich nur einen der richtig
funktioniert hat aber ich habe noch ganz
viele im petto wenn ihr sagt mach dir
auch noch last nach oben da aber nicht
den kanal zeigt auch mein 2 kanal ab und
also um einen neuen kanal und rektor ist
auch verlinkt das war's haut rein
[Musik]